[Music]
first of all my name is brian merkel
i have been working on this this manning
live project
called asynchronous event handling using
microservices and kafka
and um what that is
essentially is my goal was to provide
maybe a novice or intermediate developer
who had been looking to
to work with kafka um to give them a a
sort of like real world scenario
where they could actually implement um
kafka and
um in in a very simple way no no nothing
really too advanced but give somebody a
good sort of intro
to working with kafka in this live
stream
i wanted to sort of work with like how
do you do that from a local developer
and
developer environment right as a
developer we want uh fast feedback
and and what better way to do that than
be able to do everything we need to do
on our local machines now i'm not
inventing this information that all this
information
is out there online but um as part of my
part of my live project
the first first milestone that's there
is to set up
a kafka to run on your local machine
uh so so today i'd love to sort of show
how i've kind of gone through this
um and uh kind of take it from there
uh so essentially what i do i usually
what i start off with is i kind of go to
uh kafka playing vanilla kafka
um you probably know there's there's
probably there's a company out there
called confluence or not
is it confluent um that provides
a um kind of a supported version
of uh apache kafka um
but but ultimately you know uh they
claim you know sort of
compatibility with with the open source
version um
but as a developer who who you know
doesn't want to have to worry about
licensing and also other good stuff like
um working with open source kafka makes
a lot of sense
and so uh this is kind of where i
started um
so what i wanted to do is sort of walk
through um two two different approaches
today
on how i've worked with kafka um on some
local projects
um the first is um really just running
kafka on your local machine like running
it
um just just you know install it as a
service on your machine
now i run a mac um i know most people
some people probably run windows
um there are some some good resources
out there how to get
a kafka installed and running on windows
and i will include a few links in the
chat a little bit later on
but i have i have two sort of good
resources one actually from confluent
on how to run patching on kafka on
windows
actually using the a subsystem for linux
which is interesting um and then there's
another approach
that i found that essentially runs it
like you would
um as a service and so there is a there
is a
um when you download apache kafka there
is a
windows set of scripts that come with it
in the bin directory
that would allow you to to you know run
these things against windows
uh for today's demo i'm just going to
show how i do it through through a
sort of a unix uh shell uh on my on my
mac um but the the process and the
the steps are pretty much very identical
between how you would do it in
in on the mac and and from um you know
and then windows
so uh let's let's dive in here um
so one thing i've done ahead of time um
i've already downloaded
kafka you can actually go to if you go
to
the the apache.kafka.org you can you can
find
where to download it i'm downloading the
latest version
just to make it um you know keep keep
the latest
um ultimately uh so i've already
downloaded the file and what i've done
what i've done here is like i don't i
don't have anything running locally and
actually
i should probably just show you um
before i
do this actually let's name it the right
thing right come on if we have to copy
it
good job
if i can actually select it so i can
copy all right so
this is the uh nothing up my sleeves
thing so i have a kafka directory but if
you
if you look into that it's just um
some readme file and a docker folder
uh so here i'm gonna do i'm gonna copy
from my downloads direct directory to
this this directory
and so now if i look here i have the i
have the
tarball and then ultimately i'm gonna
like i've set up some some kind of some
good commands here to help me
uh work through this but but um one
thing i wanted to mention is that
there's there's some good references for
these things and
and i'll try to figure out a way to get
you guys these things or at least share
them in the chat
but one of the prerequisites for doing
the local install
on your machine is that you need java
you need a version of java 8 or better
i feel like i've as a developer i've
always downloaded the jdk
but i i think you can get away with just
downloading the gre
um but that mileage may vary um so you
need at least java installed
locally to run this on your local
machine
so let me go back to my uh my um
terminal window here and and i'm going
to just go ahead and use the
the nice uh provided information that um
you know apache gives us out of the box
with the quick start
because it works pretty much out of the
box
so now that i've unzipped that
we can look here and now i see a new
directory for kafka
they go in here i'm going to see uh you
know a bunch of
standard kind of stuff licenses notices
config libs licenses
um but we're concerned cons what we're
looking at here is for the bin directory
um in the bin directory itself is where
the scripts are to start and stop the
various components that you need to
start with kafka
um and as of right now um there are two
sort of components that are needed to
run in order to get kafka to run
as expected one is zookeeper
and the zookeeper is a is a server that
that essentially
helps coordinate the communication
between the nodes
and then kafka itself so there's two
services that we want to
to start with in order to get kafka
running out of the box
uh so what i like to do here is create a
new sermon window and i'm in
in the coffee directory let me go ahead
and do the first thing so the first
thing you want to do and this is what's
great about the
these quick start is it it kind of walks
you through this
you know pretty pretty good um and so
and so i don't want i didn't want to
invent reinvent this this is done
pretty simply and good out of the box on
the kafka website so
i'm gonna i'm gonna kind of sort of
stick the way that they've been doing it
here
um but ultimately you want to
you know start start zookeeper so
there's a command here it basically says
you know
do a server start on the zoo keeper and
then pass in the configuration for
zookeeper
you can configure things in zookeeper if
you really want to get more advanced on
your local
local setup but really out of the box it
works pretty well
uh so i in my in my testing and and
stuff that i've done locally i just
stick with the defaults um there are
some
you know if you're if you really want to
sort of make your installation
work like like your production or your
testing environments then maybe you want
to configure this a little differently
but
for this case it's really it really
works pretty well out of the box
it starts up pretty quick essentially
you get
it doesn't really say like oh server
started um necessarily but um
you basically get you get these uh
little
log statements in the background here um
i'm not running in the background i'm
just running it
in the foreground and so uh as logs as
events happen that that the
zookeeper wants to log it'll just log it
to this window
so it's essentially uh it also allows me
to really easily shut it down
i just do you know command c um and
it now that now it's no longer running
so let me just let's set that up again
it starts off pretty quickly a few
seconds or so
let me go ahead and jump to another
another tab and let me let me run
uh the command to start kafka itself
it's a very similar setup there's a
server start for kafka and also with
some
config server settings server properties
you can also can override them but like
i said out of the box
it works out pretty pretty well
especially for local development where
you're only running on
essentially one node in a cl in a
onenote cluster
and that's usually pretty good for
testing locally
uh so yeah here
you kind of get to know it's it's up and
running when uh you
sort of see these these last final uh
info statements here
essentially it says it started so it's
great all right cool
well that was a pretty easy right like
maybe a couple minutes of work and
if you're just copy pasting from from
the start page you can be even less than
that
all right so so the vanilla out of the
box works pretty well for what i'm
trying to do
uh typically and um you know if you
wanted to you can definitely start with
this and then you just
play it by ear like you know look at the
configuration
use the apache documentation for kafka
to see if there's other
uh properties that may make more sense
for your use case
but um so right now at this point we
have we have zookeeper running
we have kafka running and essentially
that means
we have a running kafka cluster and what
can i do with that now
well now we can excuse some commands
against it so
one of the things that we're looking to
do is is kafka is a
distributed message messaging system
using uh
topics um and a subscription so it's a
pub sub kind of model
meaning i'm gonna i can send message to
one topic and i can have multiple
subscribers who care about that
that that message in that topic and can
be can take action against that
that event uh think about um
an order being placed on a what on a
website
we want to be able to uh you know maybe
decrement the
inventory uh check for you know check
check for shipping
um uh
notify the customer that we've received
the order but those are all sort of
triggered off of one
one event so so the main sort of
component that we're looking at in kafka
is is basically a topic so we want to be
able to say
be able to create topics modify them
delete them
and then eventually be able to send
messages
to a topic and receive messages from a
topic and the way i'm going to
demonstrate that today
is using some some command line
commands to sort of help illustrate like
you don't need a
you you don't need a working
application to actually do to test that
and verify that kafka is up and running
you can actually execute the scripts
that are provided by kafka
to do this for us um so let me go ahead
and look at my little cheat sheet here
so i have some good
things here when i want to show up
showcase so the one thing i wanted to
show
is you know nothing up my sleeve we just
created this from scratch
i'm gonna i want but what i want to do
is i want to list the topics that
currently exist
and to do this we'll use some some
a command that's available in another
command
that's available inside the bin
directory called kafka topics
to to interact with the topics within
kafka
so here we have you know the command and
and with every command you typically
have to send this bootstrap
server address which is essentially uh
zookeeper's address
actually you know that's not you keep
your stress kafka's address
um anyway um and then you can sort of
run a command called list
and this basically will say you know
what what's what's what's over there
and again it returns nothing because
there's nothing there um
one nice thing is if i just get rid of
this command and obviously these these
commands are available in the
documentation but if you're already here
like just want to mess around
um you could do like dash dash help or
you could just
just hit the um you know hit the
this command without any any uh supply
command it kind of gives you what's all
of
all is available uh which is just kind
of nice you see it all
in one you have to leave your screen to
be able to see it
so yes right now we don't have anything
in there and so
the first thing i'd like to do is let's
create a new topic
and so we kind of use the same the same
topics command
um and always we're always providing the
bootstrap server
we want to do a create and then we want
to give it give a topic of the topic
name
um i'm going to sort of pretend we're
dealing with an order system
and you know we'll just create a new
topic called orders
so you get a nice little message back
saying uh
it has been created and if we went and
did our list command again now we should
see it we'll see one topic
called orders now not very good not very
much information here
uh order just showing you the topic name
is is i guess is good from a perspective
of yes i can verify my topic has been
created
but if you like a little more detail
there's a nice little describe command
that will basically give you a little
more information about the topics that
are
there um so if you give it if you give
the described command by itself it'll
list out
all the topics that are currently in
kafka and give some
pretty good information here you know
partition count replication factor
some configs so these are this is like
basically what you get out of the box
by creating a new new topic without any
other configuration
um and then um
you also said like if you actually
provided just the
topic name itself to describe it'll only
give you the information for that topic
so that's pretty pretty handy
and so then there's a nice little way to
clean up your topics if you're ready to
delete them
and it's pretty pretty clear it's pretty
simple there's a delete command
you pass in the topic that you want to
delete and
voila it goes away if i
describe i should see no topics because
that topic has been deleted
and so we do now this is
like the simplest way you can create a
topic and interact with a topic
um as far as like the top configuration
uh through this command um
but now let's look at a way that we that
we can add a little more detail
so i want to create a topic but i want
to actually
pass it a config which is basically say
i'm going to overwrite the default
configuration that this topic has
now there's there's a pl there's tons of
different configs that you can use and
you can really tune your topics
uh pretty pretty uh
there's probably a wide range of things
you can you can configure
and that's um there's this nice little
patchy uh
topic configs uh section in their
documentation that kind of gives you
some examples
and then you know gives you a really
good description about what all these
um uh parameters these configuration
parameters would do um but out of the
box
out of the box it pretty it pretty much
works uh you know the way
uh pretty well for what what you would
typically want to be testing within your
local machine
so one of the things i'm going to do is
i'm going to use i'm going to update
or override this max message bytes
config and what this is is out of the
box i believe
um uh kafka supports
uh a one one megabyte one megabyte
i think one megabyte message uh uh um
per message and so by by changing this
you can sort of say like i can i can
streamline
um uh how much how much information i
want to have i want to have kaka store
and be explicit about like yeah you know
trying to keep the size
size down if you say you're worried
about you know busting out your
your uh disk space on whatever system
you're on
you can tune these messages down to be
to be smaller or larger
depending on on the type of information
that you're sending it
um i will say that um
so kafka uses persistent storage
to uh to store its its information so
that
in in the unlikely event of an issue
like
as long as the the disc itself the
volume is
it hasn't been disturbed or
destroyed kafka can can re
can can can read back the data that that
um
you know uh is in that is is in that a
volume of data so essentially like you
can help really tune if you know if
you're trying to
do cost optimization around the the cost
of
these services and you want to be you
know
considerate of that space and you can
really tune these these topics
um in various ways to help reduce uh the
cost of the infrastructure that would
eventually be running these in like a
production environment so the only thing
different here on running this command
is um is i'm passing now in a config
and the config can take
you basically if you wanted to do
another uh configuration you just pass
in another
config switch and then the name of the
the
[Music]
property equals the value of the
property
so when i hit here i'm going to
basically see
the same message i saw at the beginning
you know we created a new orders topic
if i now go to to describe uh
all my topics i should see one and now
we can see
uh you know we have these segment bytes
that were sort of here
um at the beginning now we have an
additional one called max message bytes
so all the same you know uh
things apply here uh you can
describe it and then delete it and all
good kind of stuff
so that that's if you already know what
the configuration should be out of the
box
um you know what you what we can do is
is is do it all in one file swoop create
the topic
pass in the config parameters we like
and then we're good to go
but say you don't know that right you
don't see you don't know that i want to
i want to um
uh minimize my you know i want to
control my the
the size of the messages are coming
through at the beginning when you create
the topic
and so what we can do in that case is
uh we can do it after the fact so
essentially here let's go ahead and
delete that topic so i can create it
again
um actually i didn't mean to do that
because i want to show that a little bit
later one second let me put this back
i'm going to follow my own script here
so i want to do this with a new server
so a new topic sorry i'm going to create
a notifications topic
and this topic could be something like i
want to send a message to the customer i
want to send a message to our
shipping partners i want to send a
message to fulfillment or warehouse like
you could send one message saying hey
this guy has a new order
and these guys these other subscribers
of this topic
that are interested in that and that
event can then take action on that event
so just like normal i'm going to create
a topic called notifications that's sort
of plain vanilla
out of the box you're like you know what
three days later i find out that
the message is pretty consistently sized
like i can always
i can always make sure that the message
is going to be under you know a
meg in size and so let's let's i want to
tune that out i want to tune it after
the fact
so there's another command here called
kafka configs
that that you can run to alter the
configuration
of the topic that that's already been
created
and so how you do that is you have copy
configs uh
script you pass any bootstrap server
like always and then there's a couple
different little
nuances to how to tell this configs
thing to target what you're trying to
change
and that is there's an entity type you
tell it it's topics
and then you just give it the entity
name which is the name of the topic you
want to all to change
and then there's this alter command and
then
essentially just like we did when we
passed in the configs
um you know whenever we knew ahead of
time we just
use this add config parameter switch
and then pass it this the the same you
know
property that we did up up above
and so before i do that though
i want to say i want to just just show i
mean
you've already seen this a few times but
let's let's
let's see now what we see when you say
describe with no topic name so i should
get two topics
which i do so no orders notifications
you'll see that the
notifications topic is just you know
plain vanilla
now i'm gonna go oops did i do something
there we go so now i'm going to go ahead
and alter this topic
and add and add this new configuration
that will start limiting the bytes of
the message
and get this nice message back saying
it's been complete
and if we go to describe it i'm just
going to pass in the topic just so that
we can
see less of the nest noise
and now we see the the information on
the topic is is there and then
includes my new configuration of max
message bytes
so um yeah i'm gonna go ahead and i'm
gonna go ahead and let's
so that's that's really like just a few
commands i wanted to show
uh in this demo there's there's a few
other ones that are in there but these
ones are really
really specific to uh obviously you know
dealing with topics
and then and the configuration of the
topics um
now what i want to show is
um
that we can actually write some commands
that can actually start sending messages
and then receiving messages from kafka
from the topics
let me create a new tab here and
we know basically we're verifying that
uh
you know kafka is running zookeeper is
running that's all great
we'll get errors back if that's not the
case but essentially here what i want to
show
is there is this command
that's out there that's basically called
console producer
and what this does is it runs a it runs
a program that that's just sort of
always running
in the background here and allows you
just to send messages
to whatever topic you've described
um and so here's uh you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna start this i'm gonna send a
message to
the notifications topic so it's sitting
here it's waiting it has this little
carrot here to help you just to know
that hey i'm ready to receive some input
um i'm gonna go ahead and pass in this
json
payload it really can be any payload i
can actually just start here and say
hello
and i'm in a new in a new window i'm
going to go ahead and i'm going to
run the consumer
up basically and it would allow me to
then read from this topic as things are
happening and so that
program is called kafka console consumer
um i'm targeting the notification topic
and then basically using the switch this
is from the beginning so i'll get all
messages
uh from the from the beginning uh of
messages being sent that's not hasn't
been already
retained or sorry uh reclaimed or or
deleted
so let me run that and i should see
a hello message pop up
and there you are hello and i can say
uh live stream is awesome
and then i should see it over here so
that's kind of cool uh so then
let me go ahead and paste in my that's
not the message i was looking for
this is not the message you're looking
for
uh i gotta just hit send i hit enter on
that and that would have just sent the
same message but let me go and type
them what what i see why what i see
typically is people send
structured documents structured messages
as as as events through to kafka
that way you can it's sort of you can
provide you know
you know structured information in there
it helps the consumers of that message
be able to
uh parse it out and and um
uh you know in a structured way and
stuff like that
so i'll send that and then essentially i
get that message on the other side
man that 30 minutes sure went by fast
uh let's got four minutes left um before
i
head on the other thing i was going to
show was was was the next
um essentially uh one there's a clean up
of of this if you want to just you know
you hit ctrl c and not shut down
kafka you kind of want to shut down
kafka first uh because kafka relies on
zookeeper so
just like you you have to run zookeeper
first to launch kafka
you should do it in the reverse order so
it it
def cleans up cleanly and then
take down zookeeper and then there's
like this
nice little also this the thing that
that words about the logs
10 files that can also be cleaned up if
you want to run that too
so that's that's local do again on your
local machine
i haven't seen any questions come
through so i'm not sure if anybody
has any at this point i i have
extra time i'm not sure how this is
going to work from the streaming
perspective
this is the first one i'm done but i'm
more than willing to say a little more
if we want to look at the
my other approach which is using docker
i'll say if anybody has any questions or
concerns
or questions at all send in the chat and
give you give you like 15 seconds to see
something
before i move on
it's pretty straightforward so i i think
that should be okay
so let me just show the other quick way
that i've done this done this and
this using docker benefits of docker is
you don't have to have anything
installed on your machine except for uh
you know what i've typically see people
use docker desktop that's available on
windows and
in in the mac in linux actually um so i
have that i already have that running
you don't need java install in this case
because the other thing is a docker
container so
it um it kind of uh work works on your
benefit from that perspective
um there is a a
docker compose file that that i've used
in reference from
uh let me just pull in
so there's a there's a nice little um
tutorial that
that this guy put together that worked
out pretty well
it makes it made this the process really
simple and essentially
um you know he gives up he gives out the
the
the docker compose compose file
and instructions that are really you
know quick to set up so
only for only prerequisite is docker
desktop
uh you can go to that link to to get it
um and then essentially
let me just go ahead and show you how
how that works real quick
um because it's pretty simple actually
i'm already there
yeah i'm already there so let me
actually want to open up
the the compose file because it's pretty
straightforward
and the the reason why you want we
usually want to use compo
compose too is that it helps us create
and manage running multiple
images and containers at the same time
um
and so it's really really
straightforward to sort of set this up
so we have two containers two two
containers that we'll be running in this
process
you know zookeeper and kafka and i just
basically stole this
right from from that guy's website it
works out great it has all the right
you know the standard default ports and
the sort of minimum configuration you
need to have get docker up and running
and so really all you have to do to do
that is
called docker compose give it the name
of the configuration
say up and i'll do a bunch of good stuff
all in the uh in the same
terminal window and then essentially
it'll let you know and it's when they're
both running
usually when all the logging statements
stop stop uh
running and so those are supposedly
running
i can say um use the docker command
to say you know let me list all the
containers that are running and here we
go
you know these uh it shows you those two
ones for zookeeper
one for kafka and then i can run some of
the very
the similar commands that i've done in
the past right i can
actually execute these commands against
the running
kafka image essentially
it knows that i'm going to go ahead and
run the the top
topics script pass in the bootstrap
server
and then you know create topic orders
it should come back cool and then i can
see
you know i'm going to describe on it and
it will show me the
topic information
so um and one thing that was is kind of
interesting is
is when you're referencing the the
container you have to use
the right name when doing an ls on the
containers the names show up over here
so just
to make sure that this is the name of
this of the server that's referencing
but other than that no that was pretty
quick but we're over time
um so
yeah thank you for for joining um
uh i hope to see you uh you guys
on the live project thanks a lot i'll
see you
see you later